so what's the worst thing about the
worst thing about Marco Rubio is Cuba
Cuba is gonna be a huge issue in this
election because Obama's efforts to
reopen relations with the country of
course we're you know Rubio has a very
strong heritage
it means gonna be front and center and
his position is revanchist
I mean it just is it is a position that
Ronald Reagan would not have taken at
the same point you know it's a position
that essentially says it's it's okay for
the Cuban people to suffer because Marco
Rubio has a hang-up about communism
that's what the logic of the position is
again he has the potential to be the
Cuban American huh who takes Americans
will of America's relationship with Cuba
and in the next century on almost every
other issue Marco Rubio has a new idea
he's a man of few on the right side of
history on Cuba he is on the wrong side
of history generationally
demographically and he's impervious to
it now you could say well that's good
because he's consistent he sticks to his
position but frankly the good policy
here that virtually everyone who has
some sense about this agrees with is to
engage with Cuba to help Cuban people
and to let the Cold War be the Cold War
yeah I mean Conan O'Brien did his show
down there so clearly people want
relations there are more unclear
missiles there's no threat of nuclear
missiles from Cuba that was the big
thing there in the Cold War if you
remember yeah I mean Ronald Reagan
talked with a Soviet Union a lot engage
with them wanted to expose American
culture so you didn't want to increase
trade with the Soviet Union at the end
of his presidency second term marco
rubio is acting unlike ronald reagan
here so i find that interesting about
marco rubio's foreign policy in general
because he definitely is a throwback
more to reagan and he wants America to
assert its role in the world or what he
sees as America's role in the world more
three years ago I would have said nobody
would be going for that but I do think
the geopolitical situation in the world
is changing I tend to think that people
are going to be voting for a more
interventionist foreign policy do you
agree with that I think people are I
mean I think I think there's a sense
that America's place in the world is if
not weakened it
much less influential than it was we
seem to have much less control over what
happens and Marco Rubio is running
essentially to say well I'm going to
assert more control I'm in a certain
American values there on Cuba people
want that to mean engagement they want
intervention it doesn't them to be
military intervention yeah it means the
full panoply of power hard power soft
power talking power people power you
understand why Marco Rubio mm-hmm has
the position he hasn't Cuba but it's
it's the wrong position yes the wrong
position and and I think he knows it he
has to know it because history is moving
in the opposite direction and normally
it really wouldn't matter Cuba but it's
going but a front center in this
election and and so Marco Rubio is gonna
have to deal with Cuba and I think
that's the worst thing about him at this
point
all right Marco Rubio is his Cuba stance
the worst thing about him is foreign
policy going to be a bigger part of the
2016 election maybe then people think
it's going to be let us know your
thoughts in the comments right now